hey guys it's Thursday April
twenty-eighth I'm Mary and you're
watching gamespot news where we bring
you the latest stories from yesterday
today turns out that most of the hot
stories hit after the news yesterday so
I'm bringing them to you now let's do it
so the biggest news story to hit
yesterday was that cyberpunk 2077 is
going to be bigger than the witcher 3 on
all fronts it's pretty big CD Projekt
RED has yet again spoken up to talk
about the ambitious nature of its
upcoming RPG cyberpunk 2077 in an
interview march in of in ski says the
massive success of the witcher 3 wild
hunt which is shipped 10 million copies
by the way gives the developer more
resources an opportunity to go even
bigger with cyberpunk 2077 he says and I
quote more ambitious on every single
front in development and on the
marketing side overall CD Projekt RED
has had amazingly large ambitions for
the game to support its grand vision for
cyberpunk 2077 the studio plans to at
least double its headcount which
currently stands at around four hundred
people for us it was never about money
Vince Key said we deliver results but we
always explain to our investors that we
have a long-term perspective they
shouldn't expect us to annualize or
suddenly start releasing games just
because it's a business opportunity
fundamentally The Witcher 3 has proven
that and right now we have a lot of
credit so we should use that and take
the time to make cyberpunk something
really meaningful for the whole industry
it has to reach the quality bar and I'm
not just talking about for us for the
market if we look at our role models
what Rockstar is doing is amazing it's
not like we have to ship a game where we
might not hit our financial goals it's
here's GTA 5 and by the way it's the
best game we've ever made we're all
looking forward to red dead redemption
too because you know they'll show
something and you'll be like oh my god
yeah that's a [ __ ] this is the
coolest quote I've ever heard the other
big news story from last night was up
there's going to be an announcement for
new Xbox hardware and controller at e3
this year that's also pretty big
Microsoft will make a pair of big Xbox
hardware announcements
three in June if a new report from
Microsoft blogger Brad Sam's is anything
to go on citing sources inside Microsoft
Sam's reports on Paltrow's blog that the
company will announce a new Xbox device
at its briefing along with a new xbox
controller this pad is said to be
similar in design to the existing one
though it will reportedly come in a new
color that could be white oh my god as
for the Xbox device Sam said it could be
a new version of the Xbox one elite
console or something totally new this
will be a big year for Microsoft at e3
as the company tries once again to show
that its console is a better choice when
sized up against the ps4 the existing
Xbox one elite model is one of the most
expensive systems microsoft offers
retailing for 500 bucks though it's
marked down to 450 until the end of the
month on top of the new xbox device and
controller Microsoft may also discuss
its efforts to more deeply linked Xbox
one in Windows 10 it's part of the e3
briefing I could have ended this story
now but I have to include that Spencer
has said Xbox fans should not expect an
xbox one and a half ie ps4 k it's not
happening I'm not a big fan of the xbox
one and a half we're going to move
forward I want to move forward in big
numbers Spencer said recently for us our
xbox is doing well it performs its
reliable the servers are doing well hype
hype hype we're going to move forward
with anything like I said I want to be
really substantial change for people in
upgrade so what you're saying is xbox to
Xbox 1.75 xbox three fourth I like that
one the month
and now I'm going to treat you guys to
some news that came out today fallout 4
survival mode came out today on PC it
comes out next week on console fallout 4
is 1.5 patch has finally left beta on PC
and it's coming to consoles next week if
you're sadistic enough you can enable
the long-awaited survival mode an exact
release date and time wasn't provided
for console but we'll be hearing more in
the next few days what does survival
mode add you ask I'll tell ya just like
in real life you can't fast travel you
can catch gross diseases you'll need to
sleep and eat and you can't carry a
400-pound arsenal with you it should
seem obvious check out this hot footage
from our feature survival mode a fallout
4 should be played which you can watch
now this update also includes support
for fallout 4s next big expansion far
Harbor which is scheduled to release
next month far Harbor will be the
largest expansion coming to fallout 4 so
far Bethesda tease that it will be the
largest expansion they've ever done in
terms of land mass you want to get your
hands on that math it's going to cost us
25 bucks man yesterday had some great
news hopefully tomorrow we'll have
really good news from today we can only
hope I'll see you then